da kommen einem fast die tränen die
spritpreise klettern weiter hoch im
briefkasten post der energieversorger
für strom und gas da sind in diesem jahr
gleich mehrere hundert euro mehr fällig
und der einkaufskorb im supermarkt der
bietet weniger für dasselbe geld das
leben ist teurer geworden und das trifft
vor allem die die schon jetzt wenig
haben und der ruf nach zuschüssen wird
also lauter soll und kann der staat
eingreifen und ist die verteuerung der
energie im sinne des klimawandels nicht
auch politisch gewollt heizen tanken
einkaufen wer kann sich das noch leisten
unser thema in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen bei uns ist ulrich
schneider seit 1999 ist der
hauptgeschäftsführer des deutschen
paritätischen wohlfahrtsverbandes und
herzlich willkommen professor michael
fort er ist politikwissenschaftler und
seit 2004 vorstand der stiftung
marktwirtschaft und vor vielen jahren da
hatte auch mal das büro von friedrich
merz geleitet und ich begrüße ganz
herzlich ständigen budelmann
unternehmerinnen geschäftsführerin von
budelmann elektronik und kolumnistin bei
spiegel online und herzlich willkommen
ruhige hermann wirtschaftsredakteurin
der taz herr schneider wir merken es
alle das leben wird teurer
ganz vielen ebenen und da fragt man sich
eigentlich wer kann sich das im moment
nicht mehr leisten bei wem ist es schon
soweit wo man wirklich merkt das ist
jetzt gehabt eine andere situation als
vorher
bestimmte gruppen die sind ganz
eindeutig betroffenen klar das sind die
die schon vorher sich eigentlich nicht
mehr leisten konnten würden sie bedenken
dass wir in deutschland zwei millionen
menschen haben die regelmäßig zur tafel
gehen und sich dort ihre lebensmittel
abholen die kommen nicht nur im monat
wenn wir dann weiter sehen dass etwa bei
den grundsicherungsbeziehern also hartz
4 und altersgrundsicherung jetzt eine
erhöhung vorgenommen wurde um 0,7
prozent und die für lebensmittel
beispielsweise ein singlehaushalt fünf
euro am tag hat oder 53 euro dann wird
bei den preissteigerungen eine grenze
erreicht und wir müssen auch sehen wir
hatten vor zwei jahren schon
230.000 stromsperren weil menschen ihre
schulden nicht zahlen könnten ihre sro
beschuldigte zahlen können dass wir
zugenommen haben aber es geht nicht nur
um als wir beziehen oder eben
obdachlosen anderen menschen es geht
mittlerweile bei den preisen natürlich
auch ein in den ganzen bereich von
menschen die erwerbstätig sind und
niedrig einkommen beziehen denn wenn man
sich anschauen für die dreiköpfige
familie
zehn euro mehr jetzt im monat an strom
das macht sich bemerkbar oder aber bei
heizkosten
war 100 quadratmeter als auch drei
personen mal gerechnet 40 80 prozent
mehr nämlich von 70 euro im letzten jahr
auf jetzt zum 0 30 im monat im schnitt
das macht sich bemerkbar und da strecken
dass sich die leute und das du bist noch
viel nicht mehr wie sie wie sie
überhaupt klar kommen sollen
was man dagegen tun könnte darüber
sprechen wir natürlich im laufe der
sendung noch das so geht es eben vielen
familien frau budelmann was bedeutet das
denn für ein unternehmen das jetzt auf
so vielen ebenen eben die preise steigen
das ist sehr unterschiedlich je nachdem
welche unternehmen man betrachtet
allerdings
liegt das größte problem glaube ich
gerade darin dass man nicht mehr planen
kann man versucht seinen kunden
dienstleistungen produkte wie gewohnt
zur verfügung zu stellen aber man es gar
nicht mehr in der lage angebote zu
erstellen die länger als sechs stunden
gültigkeit haben also im elektronik
bereich in dem wir tätig sind arbeiten
wir mittlerweile teilweise so dass wir
unseren kunden sagen ja wir versuchen
jetzt einzukaufen was irgendwie möglich
ist und was es kostet müssen wir dann
später klären und die situation ist
teilweise so verfahren dass wir
ja das wird dass wir das so machen
müssen
und planbarkeit ist dann schwierig und
das wird sich natürlich auch weiter in
den im weiteren verlauf in den
lieferketten nieder schlagen und das ist
aus unserer sicht ein sehr sehr großes
problem also schwierig etwas noch zu
planen weil man eben nicht wie man
kalkulieren kann frau herrmann schauen
wir doch mal darauf erstmal nach der
ursache warum ist er so vieles so viel
teurer geworden wir haben eine hohe
inflation und all diese dinge aber
vielleicht können sie es uns einfach
nochmal ein bisschen erklären
also ich glaube dass da drei ursachen
zusammen kommen das erste ist das
einfach die energiemärkte also die
weltmärkte für öl und gas sind sehr viel
teurer geworden und weil die preise für
öl und gas steigen wird natürlich dann
auch der strom teurer wenn man sich
jetzt an guckt dass es dann der zweite
grund ja warum steigt denn überhaupt der
preis für öl und gas dann hat das
natürlich ganz wesentlich immer noch mit
der korona pandemie zu tun denn wir
erinnern und wir alle also 2020 ist in
der zeit lang hat gar nichts mehr
funktioniert nicht lockdown überall auch
in asien die lieferketten seien gestört
ist wurde nicht mehr produziert so jetzt
ist die epidemie eigentlich weitgehend
vorbei jetzt fangen alle gleichzeitig an
wieder zu produzieren alle wollen
gleichzeitig energie haben und dann wird
die einfach knapp nicht weil während der
flaute als lockdown war haben die
ölunternehmen auch nicht mehr so viel
gefördert so jetzt können sie aber nicht
wirklich ihre quellen ins unermessliche
steigern also knappheit bedeutet
steigende preise und dann dritter grund
riecht ja auch wieder nicht es gibt
diese politische krise mit russland zum
thema ukraine und das
wirkt sich vor allen dingen auf den
gaspreis aus weil russland ein sehr sehr
wichtiger gaslieferant ist und naja all
diese gründe zusammen führenden dazu das
hat herr schneider ja schon schön
dargestellt vor allem die armen
haushalte jetzt völlig überfordert sind
weil die preise so steigen könnte man
dann sagen in dem moment wo corona
vorbei ist dann entspannte sich auch
alles wieder
ja also langfristig wird es sich
entspannen aber das problem ist
natürlich das sieht man jetzt dass wir
zwar in einer globalisierten welt leben
dass die aber absolut auf kante genäht
ist also da darf es zu keiner einzigen
störung kommen sobald die lieferketten
die tankschiffe in die ölförderung wenn
da irgendwie irgendwo eine störung
auftritt dann sind die folgen so
gravierend und dauern auch so lange bis
ich das dann wieder abbaut diese welle
die sich da aufgetürmt hat dass man eben
doch jetzt wahrscheinlich noch mit dem
ganzen jahr 2022 rechnen muss bis sich
die energiepreise wieder normalisieren
wenn das so ist ist das natürlich eine
extreme belastung das haben wir gehört
wir haben das gehört bei den unternehmen
wenn es geld von ihnen also familien mit
geringen einkommen ist das der punkt wo
man sagt ja jetzt muss der staat stützen
er muss den unternehmen und auch
familien die sich das nicht leisten
können bürgerinnen und bürgern die das
finde ich das so viel ist die muster
stützen ja man ruft dann ein wenig
nachdem der das problem auch mit
verursacht hat durch die politisch
gewollten preiserhöhungen zum teil aus
klimaschutzgründen
insofern halte ich das für schwierig der
staat muss aber und beitrag leisten ich
würde es aber schon ein bisschen
differenzierter angehen viele gründe
sind benannt worden aber wir hatten beim
tanken kamen einem auch schon 2012 in
ähnlicher weise mal die tränen und die
gaspreise waren 2008 deutlich höher als
heute also die situationen sind sehr
unterschiedlich es gibt ein auf und ab
menschen passen sich auch an die
telefonieren heute auch günstiger mit
dem handy als vor sechs jahren und
vieles andere mehr es gibt veränderungen
da müssen sich auch die menschen ein
wenig darauf einstellen richtig ist aber
auch dass die ballung von strom
gaspreisen und von benzin gleichzeitig
plus inflation im kern auch bei den
lebensmitteln natürlich gerade ziemlich
harter tobak ist wo der am meisten
ankommt das ist sicher noch zu
diskutieren
zum beispiel im bereich grundsicherung
hartz 4 gibt es eine automatische
anpassung eine inflationsanpassung die
natürlich rückwirkend ist und immer ein
bisschen mit zeitverzug kommt
mechanismus der völlig überholt ist der
hat wunderbar funktioniert jetzt schon
lange nicht mehr ist aber da andere
werden nicht in ähnlicher weise
geschützt und haben diesen schutz nicht
und meine ich sehe das problem eher in
der miete derjenigen die entsprechend
arbeiten und leisten die auch ein
bisschen was ansparen und damit auch mit
der inflation jetzt entsprechend die
gelackmeierten sind also aus meiner
sicht der staat muss etwas tun er kann
ganz konkret etwas tun wenn er die
stromsteuer auf das europäisch
vorgeschriebene mindestmaß senkt die
stromsteuer und die eeg-umlage abschafft
da gibt es ja auch signale aus der
regierung beides zusammen würde den
strompreis für alle um sechs cent pro
kilowattstunde drastisch senken das käme
allen zugute und deswegen bin ich immer
für maßnahmen die nachhaltig sind die
wirklich allen zugute kommen und die
auch strukturell in die europäischen
systeme für den klimaschutz und in den
zertifikatehandel passen das wäre besser
als jetzt über den energiekosten
zuschuss.de plattenvertrag das
interessant weil jetzt haben wir die
diskussion wir sind komplett anderer
gegensätzlicher ansicht wir denken
erstens was als 4 bezieher anbelangt
oder andere menschen mit wenig einkommen
der mechanismus der sogenannten
anpassung fortschreibt der regelsatz hat
ausgedient wenn man bei einer
preissteigerung von über 5% zum rechen
ergebnis kommt dass jemand 0,7 prozent
ausgleich bekommt da muss selbst der der
keine ahnung von statistik hat
feststellen das system greift nicht denn
die menschen können sich nicht darauf
zurückziehen dass eine statistik die
brauchen geld die müssen einkaufen die
müssen sich ernähren die müssen wir
monat kommen und es wäre aufgabe der
politik wenn man feststellt mechanismus
greifen nicht mehr den so zu verändern
dass man die menschen schützt zweitens
nicht alle menschen brauchen
unterstützung sie wissen ja auch wir
haben in 2020 einer der höchsten
sparquoten überhaupt in deutschland das
heißt die menschen haben wenig
konsumiert man dem bedingt auch haben
viel auf die hohe kante gelegt und
dadurch hat sich auch in deutschland die
spaltung zwischen arm und reich noch mal
deutlich auf getan sie haben kann
aufgebaut haben wir halten es für völlig
verfehlt jetzt hinzugehen mit dandys
kann es sehr teuer die luft aus dem
haushalt zu lassen indem man eeg-umlage
vorzieht das kostet eine milliarde
monatlich in dem man plötzlich sagen
mehrwerts klausel zu unter
streichung der eeg-umlage haben die
haben ja diejenigen natürlich am meisten
die am meisten strom verbrauchen das
sind die mit den größten portemonnaies
armen menschen verbrauchen im vergleich
dazu sehr wenig strom und haben dann
auch nominal absolut die geringere
entlastung so dick haben wir es auch
nicht wir müssen die sogenannte bazooka
mal wieder einpacken und zielgerichtet
fördern die die es brauchen ich denke
wir sind nicht in der situation
haushälterisch dass wir geld einfach aus
dem fenster schmeißen frau budelmann was
würden sie sich dann was sagen sie was
wäre eine vernünftige maßnahme bleiben
wir mal bei den energiekosten was er
eifert eben gesagt wird wenn man jetzt
die eeg-umlage die soll ja schon dann ab
sommer diesen jahres dann gestrichen
werden ist das ein punkt wo sie sagen ja
das ist eine maßnahme da da gehe ich mit
das ist eine maßnahme aber es ist nur
eine von vielen die
notwendig wäre
auch unter anderem bei den ganzen
gründen fohlen kamen kann ein paar dinge
zu kurz sodass die die
die inflation ist nicht nur auf
energiekosten zurückzuführen das ist ein
großer teil und ist auch ein wichtiger
teil aber
vieles was im jahr noch zu erwarten ist
hat auch noch andere gründe und das sind
teilweise politische gründe handels
kriege die geführt werden die zu
gesteigerten rohstoffpreisen führen
nicht nur für energie sondern auch für
andere komponenten und ich fürchte eine
eine kleine stellschraube ist zwar nett
aber das wird nicht das gesamtproblem
lösen und wir sprechen beispielsweise ja
auch das ist ein thema da geht man dann
nicht gerne an aber wir müssen auch
sprechen über die zinssätze die ezb hat
auch schon vor corona viel zu niedrige
zinsen gehabt und das ist ein großes ein
großer bereich und der müsste auch
allumfassend von der regierung
angegangen werden und das ist so eine
sache die sehe ich aktuell leider gar
nicht also so ein großes gesamtkonzept
und eine große gesamt anstrengung die
uns irgendwie zu einem gemeinsamen ziel
führt und das ist gerade glaube ich
eines der zentralen probleme vielleicht
ist das aber auch gerade dann zu viel
verlangen frau habe man vielleicht ist
die frage das ganz grosse konzept ist zu
schwierig müsste man eben an kleineren
stellschrauben jetzt drehen also ganz
konkret muss man ärmere menschen muss
man die jetzt unterstützen mit der
heizkostenzuschuss das ist ja auch in
der diskussion
ja also ich bin ganz auf der seite von
herrn schneider der ja auch schon gesagt
hat dass es überhaupt nichts bringt
jetzt mit der gießkanne durchs land zu
ziehen und wirklich jeden zu beglücken
und das ist natürlich genau der effekt
wenn man jetzt so was machen würde wie
herr iphone vorgeschlagen hat also wenn
man jetzt zum beispiel einfach die
stromsteuer cup da wird ja so getan als
wäre die stromsteuer so eine art
luxus problem des deutschen staates das
stimmt aber nicht die stromsteuer wurde
1999 eingeführt damit man die
rentenbeiträge nicht so stark steigern
muss also anders gesagt die stromsteuer
von heute finanziert die renten von
heute wenn man jetzt einfach die
stromsteuer streicht dann wäre die frage
ja und was ist dann mit den renten das
heißt das kann man so nicht machen und
ähnlich ist das auch mit der eeg umlage
wenn man die streicht dann stellt sich
eben die frage ja und wie soll man denn
die ganzen klimaschutzmaßnahmen
finanzieren
die man ja wohl gestrichen darin werden
aber das heißt sie soll ja dass ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt schlauer ja ja
aber es ist nicht unbedingt schlau und
ist ein problem vor allen dingen weil es
dann genauso ist wie herr schneider dass
er beschrieben hat dann profitieren vor
allen dingen die wohlhabenden die
besonders viel energie verbrauchen das
heißt wenn man es richtig machen würde
dann wäre es genauso was sie ja auch
angesprochen haben nämlich dass man
versucht gezielt die armen familien zu
unterstützen und da gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten das erste ist dass man
hartz 4 empfängern mehr geld gibt das
zweite ist der heizkostenzuschuss für
leute die wohngeld beziehen das hat die
regierung ja schon geschlossen und das
dritte wäre dass man leuten die knapp
oberhalb der
grenze verdienen wo man wohngeld kriecht
die ja auch wenig haben dass man bei
denen auch überlegt wie man also ganz
gezielt unterstützt und das würde viel
mehr bringen als jetzt wirklich jeden
haushalt in deutschland zu entlasten
herford sie haben aber sie sind dafür
ein riesiger komplett oder frau bulmahn
danach anfangen sie jetzt an der alpha
tier frau wohnt man bitteschön
das ist nett ich bin ja komplett bei
ihnen frau herrmann das problem ist nur
die inflation über die wir ja gerade
sprechen betrifft ja alle und das ist
schon auch eine frage glaube ich denke
aber nicht jeder wissen gerettet werden
kann man das für gesamtgesellschaftlich
lösen und nicht nur für eine
gesellschaftliche gruppe die ist
natürlich wie wir gerade festgestellt
haben ganz besonders braucht das steht
auch außer frage nichtsdestotrotz
sprechen wir hier über eine größere
gesellschaftliche thematik
was sagen sie nach ihren aussagen wären
sie ja sozusagen für die gießkanne da
sagen hier zwei teilnehmer das finden
sie gar nicht gut warum sind sie doch
ich bin ich für die gießkanne das klingt
so über spendabel sondern ich bin dafür
dass alle gleich behandelt werden und
dass wir etwas machen was auch in das
europäische zukünftige klimaschutz
system mit dem zertifikatehandel besser
passt und da passt die stromsteuer von
anno tobak 1999 auch nicht mehr ganz
rein so und
man hat vieles beschlossen für irgendwas
was irgendwas finanzieren soll linke
tasche rechte tasche also insofern da
könnte ich viele beispiele auch aus dem
sozialbereich anführen wohl die sachen
anders
gewidmet wurden insofern mir geht es um
die gleichbehandlung und mir geht's auch
nicht nur darum immer statisch zu
betrachten wer ist denn irgendwo in der
einkommensskala hier und kriegt am
meisten zuwendung denn es wird ja in
diesem land das im weltweiten vergleich
so umverteilt wie kaum ein anderes mit
steuern und sozialabgaben wird ja schon
viel getan sondern es geht mir darum
auch um die anreizwirkungen und ich will
ein konkretes beispiel sagen eine
zweiköpfige familie in deutsche also
eine vierköpfige familie mit zwei
kindern in deutschland ob die
2150 euro brutto verdienen die eltern
oder ob die
3310 euro verdienen netto kommt genau
das gleiche raus weil bei dem anstieg
das wohngeld abgeschmolzen wird die
kinderzuschläge abgeschmolzen wird und
so weiter und so fort da sagt man wenn
ich das kurz abschließend darf transfer
ins rate 100 prozent so jetzt die mit
2150 euro die bekommen wohngeld voll die
kriegen jetzt noch den energiekosten
zuschuss weil der ja gekoppelt ist ein
die wohngeldbezieher am ende stehen die
besser da als diejenigen die 3300 euro
pro tonne dann frage ich mich wie soll
jemand der bei 2000 euro steht wie so
soll sich der bemühen eine andere stelle
zu bekommen sich weiter zu qualifizieren
sich weiterzubilden sich anzustrengen
überstunden zu machen wenn er am ende
schlechter dasteht als die anderen fälle
durch die kumulation von gut gemeinten
sozialleistungen und hilfen kommen wir
oft an einen punkt wo wir das gegenteil
erreichen und deswegen sagen den
sozialleistungen niedriger halten oder
streichen und keine
ich würde sagen die sozialleistungen
sind wie sie sind und die haben ihre
begründung aber nicht zusätzlich noch
den heizkostenzuschuss aber dass unsere
belastungen weil die preise steigen ja
klar deswegen bin ich ja dafür dass man
die stromkosten ab senkt die stromkosten
treffen alle und die treffen in allen
bereichen also 33 ganz kurze punkte
zuerst ihre argumentation so gerät
wieder die menschen sind ja selber
schuld die suchen sich keinen richtigen
job die hand die ihm geht es gut wir
haben wir richtig leben wenig geld geben
und dann werden wir schon sich
fortbilden werden an einer stelle so
weiter das hat musste man aber leider so
interpretieren ist gesagt habe das ist
schlicht falsch wir haben in wir haben
wir im moment 1,4 millionen arbeitslose
und über eine million aufstocker die für
kaum mehr geld arbeiten gehen und die
meisten davon
sozialversicherungspflichtig keine
minijobs die leute wollen arbeiten jetzt
so zu tun als würde man ihre
arbeitsmotivation dämpfen indem man ihn
sozialer ist um zukommen lässt ist
einfach an der realität und an die
menschen die durch nach er sei zweitens
ich gebe ihnen ja sicherlich recht als
parität da sind wir große fans von
gleichbehandlung und gleichheit und man
kann und diese gleich behandelt wenn sie
auch gleich sind wenn wir aber eine so
unterschiedliche ausgangslage in
deutschland haben das einkommen
anbelangt zwischen arm und reich dann
kann ich nicht mit der gießkanne oder
mit der sense hingehen da muss ich etwas
genauer hin ein ungleiches muss auch
ungleich im zweifelsfalle behandelt
werden das ganze heißt am ende
solidarität und das dritte wenn man
wirklich verstellt ist kommt zu einer
abschmelzung wenn man beim wohngeld ist
die antwort ganz einfach unter knüpft an
dem an was frau herrmann sagte wie
erreichen wir auch die die knapp über
wohngeld sind nach unserer ansicht muss
müssen die grenzen für das wohngeld
ohnehin erweitert werden wir haben das
muss man sich vorstellen wir haben nur
16.000 haushalte im wohngeld bei 7
millionen armen haushalten das alles ja
fast eine symbolische leistung wir sagen
wir müssen die einkommensgrenzen höher
setzen und wir müssen auch dafür sorgen
dann am ende dass mehr menschen anrecht
auf wohngeld haben um armut zu bekämpfen
und jetzt in dieser situation denen zu
helfen die auf knapp über dem sehr eng
bemessenen vogels sind nervös wird
tschuldigung erster januar
frau
widerspricht gerade aber ganz kurz nur
im januar 2020 wohngeld ist angehoben
worden der bezirk kreis erweitert worden
januar 20 das wohngeld ist deutlich
angehoben worden januar 22 es eine
dynamisierung an die mieten und die
einkommens in der burka für ja aber sie
ist jemand weil die grenzen so eng sieht
den satz einfach zur kenntnis ok frau
bulmahn sie wollten was dazu sagen wir
diskutieren hier ja
diskutieren hier ja eigentlich nicht
über das deutsche sozialsystem
zumindest war das nicht angedacht
sondern über die preissteigerung und ein
aspekt der jetzt gerade in der
diskussion völlig außen vor gelassen
wurde ist dass die stromkosten nicht nur
von reichen und von armen bürgern
bezahlt werden müssen sondern auch von
unternehmen
und die beziehung kein wohngeld und auch
sonst keine sozialleistung die zahlen
aber auch stromkosten wenn wir also über
eine entlastung der stromkosten reden
heißt es auch dass wir unternehmen
entlasten und da sprechen wir auch nicht
immer nur von energie starten
großkonzernen sondern der großteil der
deutschen unternehmen ist
mittelständisch geprägt das würde ich
nur gerne noch mal so ein bisschen mit
in die diskussion einführen wollen dass
wir
destruktiven mal noch mal darüber
nachdenken was denn auch wirtschaftlich
gesamtwirtschaftlich und dadurch eben
den unternehmen hilft die ja dass ich
aber sagen was vergangenen jahren sehr
unter den corona maßnahmen gelitten
haben dann machen wir nochmal etwas
konkreter frau budelmann gibt es etwas
wo sie mit ihrem unternehmen wenn sie
sagen sie können im moment ist es schwer
zu planen dass die diese teuerungsrate
mit mit einzupreisen sozusagen gibt es
etwas und sagen das würde ihnen jetzt
konkret helfen bräuchten sie ja eine
gewisse förderung irgendetwas wo sie
sagen da müsste der staat auch mir als
unternehmerin unter die arme greifen
ja was förderung angeht hatten wir haben
wir gerade jan aktuellen fall
der der sehr stark durch die medien
gegangen ist nämlich die streichung der
förderung für kfw bauten sowohl der 55er
standard als auch der vierziger standard
wurde ja kurzfristig vom
bundeswirtschafts und klimaministerium
gestoppt es geht um hier energie braucht
hier also von dem man wohnt anträge
hätten gestellt werden sollen und noch
nicht gestellt wurden bis zu dieser
frist was mit diesen anträgen passieren
soll das ist so ein beispiel wenn wir
auch über teuerungsraten reden
dass das wäre sicherlich hilfreich
sowohl für den privaten wohnungsbau als
auch für unternehmen die aktuell sich im
bau befinden wir haben ja vorhin auch
darüber gesprochen wie das es eben
klimapolitische ziele gibt die auch geld
kosten das wäre jetzt zum beispiel einen
fall gewesen wo man sich sowohl als
privatpersonen als auch als unternehmen
auf die bundesregierung verlassen hat
und dann festgestellt hat naja du hast
dich verlassen dann bist du verlassen
und das war glaube ich eine bittere
erfahrung also sie hatten den alten sie
hatten konkreten antrag gestellt auf
diese förderung die sie jetzt die jetzt
erstmal ausgelaufen sind ist es richtig
und die gestellten anträge würden wir
haben also wie speziell nicht wir haben
den antrag zur vorbereitung gehabt damit
dafür muss man sehr teure energie
beratung bezahlen das haben wir alles
vorgeschaltet wir hätten quasi in der
woche darauf den antrag gestellt aber
sinnlich no wir sind ja sehr viele die
betroffen sind zu gehen war es als auch
unternehmerisch aber da würde ich jetzt
auch gerne mal was sagen ja also es kann
nicht das ziel sein des staates der
häuser zu subventionieren die eigentlich
schon soweit technisch ausgereift sind
dass sie diesen energiestandard jetzt
eigentlich auch ohne staatliche
förderung erreichen also muss es mal so
hart sagen der deutsche steuerstand das
nicht darauf herein hierhin häuser zu
finanzieren 55 handelt also ob
er wie gesagt durch deutsche steuerstaat
ist nicht dazu da einfamilienhäuser zu
finanzieren ganz prinzipiell
einfamilienhäuser sowieso schon sehr
stark gefördert und viele leute haben
mich das geld einfamilienhäuser zu
kaufen sondern sind einfach nur mieter
für die passiert aber nichts so und
jetzt hat man ja eine übergangsregel
haben wichtig wäre einen sozialen
wohnungsbau diese themen sind
einfamilienhäuser
und das thema massiv herunter zu kommen
es sieht so aus es sind 24.000 anträge
da gewesen und dann wurde gesagt nein
die machen wir nicht und dann wurde aber
gesehen so rechtlich geht das einfach
richtig anträgen ja nun mal vor man hat
jetzt beschlossen der in der letzten
woche dass diese 24.000 anträge bei dem
die mittel das nicht mehr sagen denn das
problem hat wirklich nicht mehr die
größenordnung die gerade so gewährt
wurde ok die frage ist aber dass diese
eher grundsätzlichere weil wenn sich
eben preise anders entwickeln wenn es
eine hohe inflation gibt immer die frage
nach der rolle des staates wie sehr muss
der staat ausgleichen und wie sehr
müssen leute einfach sehen wie sie damit
zurechtkommen sie sagen der staaten
muster viel stärker eingreifen
ich sagte dass des staates muss sehen
seine aufgabe ist es zwei dinge muss
einerseits diese gesellschaft
zusammenhalten das heißt eine
auseinanderbrechen der gesellschaft wird
ja wird uns allen schaden das heißt er
muss schon sehen wie halte ich die
ränder beieinander und wie schaffe ich
sie haben den begriff vorn gebracht mehr
gleichheit letztlich so dass ich auch
handlungsfähig bleibe als staaten er
muss ein zweites tun im moment er muss
nämlich die gesellschaft zusammenhalten
und gleichzeitig eine sehr engagierte
das anders problem müssen uns langsam
mal gewöhnen eine sehr engagierte
klimapolitik betreiben was hilft hilft
ja nichts wenn der staat hier was weg
generiert er muss also in großem maße
und da spielt inflation wieder rein muss
er dafür sorgen dass durch entsprechende
umverteilungs maßnahmen
alle menschen in diesem großen wandlungs
transformationsprozess in dem wir stehen
nun mitgenommen werden ganz überhaupt
geht also die kriegen da sind wir durch
15 reichsten land auf der welt also vom
gemessen am bruttoinlandprodukt also
wenn wir es nicht schaffen dann schafft
es keiner und natürlich wenn ich mir
anschaue dass wir alleine während der
pandemie unser
geldvermögen auf privaten bankkonten
oder aktienpakete und ähnlichem auf 7,7
billionen euro mittlerweile hoch
geschraubt waren dann sage ich mir wir
haben natürlich alle möglichkeiten man
muss nur den mut man muss es intelligent
nutzen und man darf das kind nicht das
wiederhole ich immer wieder mit der
gießkanne zum fenster raus muss wie
ehrlich muss sich die politik da machen
diese die klimaziele die ja gewollt sind
von allen deutschland klimaneutral bis
2045 zu sagen ja das wird etwas kosten
und hohe energiepreise sind letztendlich
gewollt um weniger zu verbrauchen das
müsste man das müsste man ehrlicher
benennen und als die als die grünen 1998
damals unter großem aufschreie die fünf
d-mark vorgeschlagen haben für einen
liter benzin wir sind ja heute nicht so
weit davon weg und waren es 2012 auch
nicht da gab es einen riesigen aufschrei
da hat aber niemand darüber diskutiert
dass man das für einige von mir aus
reiche porsche fahrer nur gelten lässt
und den anderen dann sofort einen
ausgleich zahlt natürlich sind von der
politik lenkungswirkung über preise
gewünscht und dann muss man das
eigentlich auch ehrlich sagen und
insofern ist das jetzt ein stück weit
verlogen zu sagen wir haben da etwas in
gang gesetzt weil wir das hehre ziel
klimaschutz hochhalten durchaus
begründet und gleichzeitig den leuten zu
verschweigen dass klimaschutz einen
preis hat also sozial verträglicher
klimaschutz ist ein stück weit wie
geröstete schneebälle und ist schwierig
also man muss das zumindest ehrlicher
diskutieren und nochmal ich will
beim deutschen sozialsystem ich sehe
vieles nicht so wie herr schneider das
dargestellt hat auch die 230.000 strom
sperrungen in den letzten jahr er hat
gesagt dass wir sind sicher mehr
geworden es waren 2017 100000 mehr da
warens 330.000 also das beispiel kann
man ebenso wenig nehmen das mit den
tafeln hat ich auch nicht für richtig
und die gießkanne wir sind glaube ich
beide gegen die dies kann die frage ist
nur wie wir die gießkanne definieren und
wo was zielgerichtet landet und eines
finde ich ist bei der diskussion
besonders wichtig der feind der größte
feind inflation ist der taschendieb des
kleinen mannes hat norbert bömer gesagt
der große feind sitzt feind ist
übertrieben aber das problem sitzt im
moment in frankfurt und heißt
europäische zentralbank bei die
europäische zentralbank ihrem
kernauftrag geldwertstabilität zu
sichern nicht nachkommen sondern
stattdessen wirtschafts förderpolitik
betreibt klimaschutzpolitik betreibt
europäische umverteilung betreibt und
staatsfinanzierung betreibt alles ohne
demokratisches mandat insofern muss da
eine wende erfolgen weil die inflation
uns allen wehtut auch den sparern die
angeblich so viel vermögen auf der kante
frau herrmann sie schütteln den kopf hab
ich gesehen möchten widersprechen
ja also ich meine wir hatten ja vorhin
die ursachen für die inflation schon
besprochen die ursachen sind die korona
krise und die ursachen sind vor allen
dingen auch ölpreise auf den
weltfinanzmärkten das heißt die ezb hat
mit der inflation überhaupt nichts zu
tun nicht oder anders gesagt die ezb ist
kein öl scheich selbst wenn die ezb
jetzt die zinsen hoch setzen würde wäre
der preis für öl weiterhin teuer und man
hätte weiterhin eine inflation so das
heißt die ezb hat da gar keine macht im
augenblick diese inflation irgendwie zu
bekämpfen aber es wäre nicht folgenlos
wenn sie die zinsen hoch setzen würde
sondern das ist ja klar wenn in dem
moment wo kredite teurer werden das wäre
da sind bei diesen zinsanhebungen wäre
der effekt dass eben weniger investiert
würde die gefahr wäre groß dass die
wirtschaftskrise wieder beginnt die wir
jetzt gerade so langsam hinter uns
lassen was die ganze kroner
krise wieder zurückkommt die meisten
länder auch deutschland haben sich von
der korona krise noch nicht richtig
erholt das ist jetzt nicht so dass wir
schon auf dem stand von 2009 10 wären
also das wäre dann so dass das ergebnis
wäre völlig bizarr nicht die leute
hätten dann zinsen aber ihr job wäre weg
nicht wegen der arbeitslosigkeit wegen
der krise jetzt muss man aber mal sagen
dass die meisten leute von ihrem lohn
leben und nicht von den zinsen die sie
auf ein sparbuch kassieren das heißt es
wäre einfach nur kontraproduktiv wenn
die ezb jetzt die zinsen hoch setzen
wird frau wurde maria jepsen sie den
kopf ich glaube dass jetzt wollen sie
widerspricht ganz sagen da muss ich ganz
allergisch wieder hören wir sprechen ich
empfehle dazu ein aktuelles interview
mit frau gründen wirtschaftsweise die
sehr gut aufschlüsselt das korrekt die
ezb nicht ölproduzent ist richtig aber
das wie gesagt das öl nicht die einzige
komponente der inflation ist und das ist
bei den platz und bei der ganzen
problematik auch in zukünftige
inflationserwartungen geht und das ist
die thematik die sie gerade aufgemacht
haben frau herrmann deswegen einer
kleinen zinserhöhung auf einmal alle
menschen arbeitslos werden oder eine
signifikante anzahl die die sorge kann
ich ihn nehmen wir haben ein
fachkräftemangel und wir reden gerade
was inflation angeht konkret von einer
ganz konkreten gefahr einer
lohn-preis-spirale
gleichzeitig drohen wir gerade was das
wirtschaftswachstum angeht auch in große
probleme zu beraten
die die sorge kann ich ihn nehmen frau
herrmann okay noch mal alle konkreten
hilfe lohnt dafür 1 ja okay dann noch
ersten solo und preisspirale never let
alone preisspirale das wäre tatsächlich
gefährlich nur gibt es die im augenblick
nicht 2021 sind in deutschland die
tariflöhne um 17 prozent gestiegen das
ist wenig das ist auch das worum sie das
ist sozusagen ungefähr auch die
prozentzahl um die die löhne in
deutschland steigen sollen das heißt man
kann nicht bei einer lohnsteigerung von
1,7 prozent erzählen jetzt hätte man
eine lohn-preis-spirale nein es ist so
schlecht die energiepreise sind zentral
bei der inflation die energiepreise sind
um 18 prozent gestiegen und die
nahrungsmittelpreise um sechs prozent
und der rest praktisch gar nicht und das
jetzt einfach um zu definieren ist es
aus meiner sicht abwegig okay
dann haben sie angst und darauf
basierend ist zu erwarten dass die löhne
die löhne steigen werden sowie andere
partner und natürlich ist eine
lohn-preis-spirale ein realistisches ein
problem ist das wäre das 1 1 der
richtige schritt der richtige schlüssel
erscheint dass man sagt wir müssen die
löhne müssen gesteigert werden das war
ja gerade mal im besten fall sind hilfs
argument was wir gehört haben also jetzt
von von meinungsumfragen bei den
menschen natürlich immer deutschland
haben immer menschen alles von
pflanzungen begriff nur sagt das hat
historische gründe auch jetzt zu
schließen auf eine kommende lohn preis
spirale ist vorsichtig formuliert sehr
mutig nein ich denke wir brauchen was
wir brauchen ist wenn wir die vor uns
stehenden aufgaben bewältigen wollen und
dann sollten wir auch so ehrlich sein
dass man das auch nur mit einer gewissen
inflation immer schaffen wird wenn man
sagt energie muss seinen preis haben
dann schließt sich schlagen sich
energiekosten immer in allgemeinen
produktionskosten wieder alles muss
produziert werden unter einsatz von
energie alles muss transportiert werden
und man hat ihm eine allgemeine erhöhung
von lebenshaltungskosten anders geht es
gar nicht weil wir auch alle unternehmen
versuchen im preis ihre kosten weiter
zungen wenn man das hat dann kann man
natürlich die herausforderung auf dauer
die vor dem verstehen nur schaffen wenn
wir eine anschlussquote tarifpolitik
haben auch muss nichts vor die
gewerkschaften haben aber in deutschland
immer bisher an dem punkt
außerordentlich verantwortungsvoll
agiert man kann den nie vorwerfen zu
keinem zeitpunkt dass hier die
allgemeinen volkswirtschaftlichen daten
außer acht gelassen wurden aber wir
kommen um eine solche tarifpolitik und
auch um einen vernünftigen schritt bei
erhöhung mindestlöhne überhaupt nicht
herum wenn würde die spaltung noch
weiter vorangeschritten
anwendungen speicher nicht noch weiter
treiben wollen und wir dann läuten
menschen einfach abhingen in diesen
transformationsprozessen als würde ich
schon sagen wenn wir das tun wird in
unserer demokratie wissen zum glück eine
demokratie
die politik die wir brauchen um dem
klimaproblem herr zu werden keine
mehrheiten mehr finden sie wird dann
nicht mehr die mehrheit finden die sie
braucht um
sich zu retten und deswegen geht es nur
öko sozial das wird niemals nur
ökologisch geht es kann nur öko sozial
aber trotzdem wird es ja herten geben
hirai fort was wird was trauen sie da
der neuen koalition zu dass es ebenso zu
sozial gerechtes und ökologisch ist dass
das wirklich so miteinander verbunden
wird und teilen sie die ängste von herrn
schneider da ich teile ich teile manche
sorgen ich teile insbesondere auch die
inflationssorgen der vieler menschen die
ich für begründet halte auch wenn ich
auf meinungsumfragen selber nichts gehe
und weiß dass gebe und weiß dass das
thema in deutschland auch ein bisschen
historisch besetzt ist in anderen
ländern anders besetzt herr schneider
hat gerade die südeuropäische auffassung
variante vorgetragen dass eben inflation
immer ein bisschen dazu gehört und man
das auch ein bisschen entspannter sehen
kann man muss es den leuten nur ehrlich
sagen eine inflation von vier prozent in
deutschland bedeutet dass der deutsche
staat 90 prozent 90 milliarden weniger
staatsschulden praktisch hat durch die
entwertung schuldenlast der ein
interesse an inflation deswegen lassen
die staaten von nordeuropa bis süd
europa die ezb auch ein stück weit
laufen der staat hat ein interesse an
inflation und so ein bisschen inflation
haben wir immer zwei prozent inflation
das ist ja das ziel der ezb zwei prozent
inflation wir haben ihm mehr als das
doppelte im moment über 20 jahre heißt
ein drittel der zugesagten rentenhöhe
ist weg mit der kaufkraft also das muss
man den leuten auch ehrlich erklären und
deswegen haben die leute was ihre
altersversorgung und vieles betrifft zu
recht auch angst vor der inflation und
deswegen müssen wir diese themen
entsprechend diskutieren die inflation
ist ein hauptgegner und vor allem er
schadet den kleineren leuten und er
schadet denen die mühsam was gespart
haben und er nimmt auch die anreize
etwas zu sparen und deswegen glaube ich
der ezb ehrlich gesagt kein wort wir
haben seit dem letzten sommer inflation
in deutschland messbar höher da hat frau
schnabel uns überall erzählt ja das sei
nur mehrwertsteuer holen da effekt und
klein-klein jetzt hören wir es sind die
ölpreise wird sich alles beruhigen nein
ist wird sich nicht beruhigen weil die
schulden so da sind wie sie sind und
weil wir wenn wir um auf ihre frage zu
kommen wenn wir eine ökologisch und
sozial gerechte gesellschaft voll die
gleichzeitig die im klimaschutz auch
möglich voran kommt und das müssen wir
ja irgendwo wir werden nicht alles
gleichzeitig machen können also dass
alles so bleibt wie es ist dass wir mehr
in den klimaschutz der seinen preis hat
investieren dass wir mehr nach europa
geben auch an transfers so wie es die
bundesregierung sagt das kann zusammen
nicht funktionieren und man musste es
mit den leuten wenigstens offen
diskutieren frau wurde man was
befürchten sie denn da
ja ich will keine frau budelmann dazu
gern noch mal noch mal hören was was aus
ihrer unternehmerischen sicht also wo
sehen sie denn die möglichkeit dass man
eben diese ökologische und das soziale
dann miteinander hinbekommt
sie meinen was ein unternehmen dafür tun
kann da reagiert oder ja unter uns
politisch jetzt benötigt also im grunde
was sie dafür tun
ja was wir tun können als unternehmen
ist in erster linie überhaupt überleben
das ist das was die unternehmen jetzt
nach zwei jahren pandemie machen können
und machen müssen vor allen dingen wäre
es für uns wichtig dass wir als
unternehmen auch wieder gut ins arbeiten
kommen und vor allen dingen auch ohne
staatliche zuschüsse die ganz die die
korona hilfen wurden wieder verlängert
das ist auf der einen seite natürlich
erfreulich weil man damit arbeitsplätze
sichert auf der anderen seite
verhindern wir natürlich durch weitere
massnahmen dass sich die wirtschaft so
anpasst wie es eben notwendig sein
könnte ähnliche problematiken liefert
das kurzarbeitergeld das auch weiter
verlängert worden ist
aber das hilft gehen doch das
kurzarbeitergeld hilft ihnen doch
nein das kurzarbeitergeld hat geholfen
in einer in der anfangsphase der
pandemie damals als niemand wusste wie
es weitergehen würde und sich niemand
einstellen konnte auf irgendwas da war
es sehr wichtig und es war eine
großartige hilfe aber wenn man sowas
über zwei jahre lang weiter streckt dann
muss man sich irgendwann die frage
stellen wer soll das bezahlen und dann
sind wir wieder bei unserer gießkanne
von anfang an über die wir gesprochen
haben irgendwann müssen wir über
zielgerichtete themen reden und
tatsächlich müssen wir irgendwann auch
darüber reden dass wir wieder alles ins
richtige arbeiten kommen oder es geht
noch völlig an den fakten fußball das
kurzarbeitergeld ist doch heute faktisch
der außerordentlich zielgerichtete
maßnahme weil der der größte teil geht
doch bestimmte branchen deshalb war der
ganze bereich gastronomie der ganze
bereich messe ist eine ganze bereich
kunst kultur da geht kurzarbeit hin wir
haben auch heute nicht mehr die sechs
millionen die wir mal an der spitze wir
haben heute 47 800 1000 kurzarbeiter
noch also relativ wenig und wenn wir das
jetzt streichen führen hiess das ganz
klar dass wir bestimmte branchen zum
beispiel ganze messewesen etc einfach
mal ausradieren also ich kann wirklich
und das hat mit argumentation was ich
gerade gehört haben überhaupt mehr zu
tun das ist mittlerweile zielgerichtete
maßnahmen sofort jedes
6 millionen und ganz gezielt auf eine
branche wenn sie es in ihrer firma nicht
brauch ist doch schön dass er doch genau
das ist am anfang werde man schauen wo
jetzt brauchen es auch noch diejenigen
die durch die notwendigen chor ohne
einschränkungen ihre geschäfte nicht
nachgehen können die aber sehr wohl dort
mitarbeiter haben und hoffen dass im
nächsten sommer wieder am start sind
wollen wir jetzt denen die hoffnung
nehmen das wäre fatal ist unsere
gesellschaft gar nicht aus und frage ist
nur wie viel kann der staat immer dann
geben wir sehen sind in frankreich
bekommen die menschen jetzt haushalts
schecks von 100 euro die können sie dann
nutzen wir reden gerade davon in dieser
bundesregierung die wollen monatlich
durch eine vorgezogene abschaffung der
eeg-umlage eine milliarde mal eben drauf
hauen und dann sollen wir das geld nicht
haben um 800.000 menschen kurzarbeit zu
finanzieren das kann nicht sein das sind
also dass das passt nicht die aber mit
dazu passt doch nicht die frage wie man
jetzt konkret ist weil viele menschen
machen sich sorgen und merken dass sie
eben weniger geld haben weil die preise
zu steigern gibt es in einen punkt außer
der streichung der eeg-umlage wo man
sagt da soll man solche ähnlich wie in
frankreich jetzt jedem haushalt 100 euro
geben frau herrmann wäre das eine
richtige maßnahme
also den einkommensschwachen sollten die
gießkanne ja eher einkommensschwache
haushalte da wir da wäre ganz wichtig
dass man eben vor allem auch die noch
mal bedenkt die knapp oberhalb des
wohngeld sind und im augenblick nicht
richtig unterstützt werden und dass man
gleichzeitig dafür sorgt dass sie hartz
4 empfänger angemessen unterstützt
werden denn das was sie in ording
bekommen das reicht nicht damit sie ihre
stromrechnungen bezahlen können und
eigentlich würde ich noch mal gerne wenn
das erlaubt ist auf dieses inflations
argument eingehen weil das ja etwas ist
was tatsächlich sehr viele leute sehr
stark beschäftigt ich möchte noch einmal
allen sagen dass es nichts mit der ezb
zu tun hat dass kann man sich ganz
leicht überlegen wir haben seit 2016
also schon den letzten fünf jahren haben
wir eine nullzinspolitik um den euroraum
zu stabilisieren und die deutschen sind
sehr abhängig vom euro raum denn dahin
exportieren wir nicht wir sind eine
exportnation wir brauchen käufer aber in
dieser ganzen zeit seit 2016 gab es
eigentlich überhaupt keine inflation
sondern die inflation hat erst
angefangen und man kann es genau sehen
in dem moment wo die energiepreise
gestiegen okay das sagen seitdem pro tag
legen
wir haben noch drei minuten deshalb das
ist ja der punkt haben wir aber jetzt so
gemacht dass an den energie ich würde
gerne mal wissen wäre es wichtig dass
man jetzt ja etwas luft raus nimmt
sozusagen den druck da etwas raus und
eifert indem man bestimmten
einkommensschwachen haushalten einfach
sagt ja ihr habt jetzt einfach mal 100
200 euro kriegt er jetzt mal macht das
sinn so etwas
ein satz wie zb derjenige der vom
sechsten stock gesprungen ist und am
offenen fenster des ersten stocks
vorbeiflog und da sagte es ist alles
wunderbar ich fühle mich bestens so
kommt mir das vor was hier so zur ezb
gesagt wird nochmal entlastung in
deutschland ich glaube das ist eine
entlastung bei den strompreisen geben
muss das ist das durch dienste problem
mit den steigerungen seit inzwischen 20
jahren da muss eine entlastung geben
einzusteigen ja aber man kann nicht
punktuell man kann er ist auch nicht
unterschiedliche milchpreise für
unterschiedliche einkommensgruppen
machen wie gesagt bei grundsicherung und
so wird ist hier angepasst herr
schneider findet das wird mich
ausreichend angepasst darüber muss man
diskutieren auch über den zeitraum der
anpassung kann man diskutieren aber es
wird angepasst diesen schutz haben
andere arbeitende leute nicht in der
bevölkerung und der ist zumindest mal da
und ich finde strompreis stromsteuer
absenken eeg-umlage abschaffen ist etwas
was nachhaltig dass der energiekosten
zuschuss ist jetzt ein einmaliges bonbon
und pflaster was nachhaltig und
dauerhaft hilft und was allen hilft und
deswegen finde ich das fair und ich
finde man kann schon auch sagen dass
kein land in corona so viel ausgegeben
hat um unternehmen und bürgern zu helfen
wie deutschland in europa in der ganzen
eu und kein land hat in den letzten
jahren systematisch in jedem jahr die
sozialausgaben über der
wirtschaftsleistungen erhöht und in den
letzten jahren sind in deutschland auch
insgesamt die löhne und renten weit über
inflation angestiegen also irgendwo sich
auch spielräume den menschen entstanden
ganz kurz zu zerstoßen wenn mit der
erhöhung des mindestlohnes auf 12 euro
gibt es da nicht einfach dann auch eine
entspannung gerade schrecklichen
entspannung für etwa 67 millionen
menschen und war für diejenigen argument
aufzugreifen die trotz der reallohn
zuwächse die wir tatsächlich hatten in
deutschland für strecke geblieben sind
denn die obersten zehn prozent beim
einkommen die konten 24 prozent
tatsächlich letzten zehn jahren ihr
einkommen steigern die unteren zehn
prozent sind trotz zuwächsen im lohn
nach wie vor nicht mal auf dem niveau
des jahres 2000 wir haben eine schere in
deutschland wir haben eine spaltung in
deutschland es kommt jetzt darauf an sie
zu gewinnen und bei der inflation dafür
zu sorgen dass jeder über dem monat
kommt das ist das erste ziel okay gut
klare ziele und klare gegensätze auch
hier sind glaube ich sehr deutlich
geworden vielen dank frau herrmann frau
budelmann herr schneider und herbert und
vielen dank ihnen liebe zuschauer für
das interesse hier geht es weiter bei
phoenix der tag mit konstanzer platz
gehen bis dann
[Musik]